there was spring 1967 LBJ was in the
White House the Vietnam War was in full
swing and the biggest musical act in
America was the month in that same
spring a chance encounter in New York
City's Greenwich Village would kick off
one of the strangest and most ill-fated
intersections of pop culture in history
[Music]
here's monkey charmer
Mickey Dolan somebody said you got to
come down and see this incredible guitar
player that plays guitar with this piece
there was no name attached nothing that
no-name guitar player was none other
than rock-and-roll legend in the making
Jimi Hendrix flash-forward did you know
that year
it's the Monterey Papa and I'm sitting
in the audience all of a sudden out
walks means three readily decorated
characters and I just remember going
that's the guy who plays guitar with his
teeth and of course by then they were
the Jimi Hendrix Experience
Mickey was impressed everybody was blown
away and I told our producers you've got
to check this guy out because we were
looking for an opening act and despite
some fairly obvious differences in
musical style a deal was struck turn up
the opening act of the Monkees was the
Jimi Hendrix Experience a new group Jimi
Hendrix Experience traveling with the
Monkees and they joined the Monkees
concert tour for the two acts hit the
road but as it turned out fans would
come to see the monkeys weren't quite
sure what to make of Jimi Hendrix he
would go on stage to open air and he'd
be going foxy lady and we won baby we
want the mug it was kind of embarrassing
perfectly and things didn't get much
better as the tour continued and after
only seven shows Jimi had had enough I
didn't hear the rumor at one of the last
shows he finally flipped off the
audience
I don't believe me financially and just
like that the unlikely marriage of
Hendrix and the monkeys had come to an
end
Jimi of course went on to be Wow Jimi
Hendrix possibly the greatest rock and
roll guitarist ever horizontally I'd
like to think that we might have had
something to do with it but I think he
would have done okay with herself
opening for the Monkees
you
[Music]